est difficile d'imaginer qu'il y a une
dizaine d'année des élèves avec ou entre
ses murs ou que des collégiens cours est
ici à l'heure de la récréation fermé en
2007 le collège bergson et désormais un
vaste chantier depuis le mois de janvier
les ouvriers sont les nouveaux maîtres
des lieux que là nous terminons le
désamiantage et nous terminons également
donc nous sommes en plus un curage c'est
à dire que vous enlevez ont toutes les
cloisons intérieures les doublages la
poitrine et radiateurs voilà pour qu'il
nous reste qu'à la fin que du béton une
véritable mise à nu du bâtiment donc qui
précède une démolition à partir du mois
de mai c'est alors que débutera la
véritable construction d'un projet phare
pour la ville promesses de campagne en
2014 le nouveau pôle culturel de quatre
étages l'installation des danseurs
musiciens et amateurs de théâtre est
prévue en 2020 dans des locaux
ultramodernes au coeur du quartier de la
sourde oreille
il est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
dans les locaux actuels tout ce qui est
sono et autres ne correspondent pas du
tout et parce que j'ai une certaine
vétusté donc là oui on aura une offre
complémentaire ou supplémentaires dans
des locaux vraiment adapté le nouveau
site verra aussi la construction de 136
logements répartis autour du centre
culturel coût net de l'opération pour la
ville 8 millions d'euros
la ville qui a lancé un concours
jusqu'au 1er juin pour trouver un
nouveau nom à l'établissement preuve
sûrement qu'une page se tourne à
montigny le bretonneux